In this next section, we want to do a quick overview of our tracking solution, plugins,
and system operations as we prepare for our Lens file calibration.
You'll see here in virtual production in ICDFX a list of our plugins.
The plugins that you have here in blue, the Aja Media Player, Blackmagic Media Player,
Camera Calibration, LED Wall Calibration, Live Link Camera, Live Link Lens, and Open
CV Lens Distortion are all the plugins that we need active for our calibration.
As I mentioned before, the Latte stage uses the OptiTrack system with Motive, and we
need to have those OptiTrack Live Link and Streaming Client plugins made available for
our Unreal Engine plugin.
Anything that you see here in orange, those are our virtual production-related plugins,
and those can be implemented as well.
Now, our options for our tracking system.
The Latte stage, as I've mentioned, uses the OptiTrack Motive system for performance
capture and for our camera and object tracking.
We also use this for nodal point calibration and lens distortion mapping, but there are
other options that are available to you, Vicon Showgun, the Vive Tracker, as well as the
Vive Mars system.
Note, you want to make sure that when doing camera tracking, it should be active as part
of your stage setup.
Your tracking setup, including setting the origin point, or the 000 of your tracking
volume for camera calibration and lens distortion mapping, are also covered in some of this
course.
However, there is plenty of documentation on the various vendors' tracking solution
websites, and there's a lot of video documentation that you can follow to go through these steps
on your own.
Now, in our next section, we're going to take a look at some of our camera control systems
before we build ourselves a virtual Live Link subject.
Thanks for watching.
I hope you enjoyed this video.
I'll see you in the next one.
Bye.